the real mental health issue
might actually be the Republican Party
the uh there is a new piece in the new
Republic by Michael tomasky called the
main mental health issue in this country
is in the Republican party and this
piece makes a number of really good
points one of the points that the piece
makes and I encourage you to read it is
that red States allocate way less money
for treating mental illness than do blue
States and in fact if you look at a map
and and we're putting such a map up on
the screen you can see that generally
speaking red states are much lighter
colored meaning they devote a much
smaller share of their budgets towards
mental health treatment that we know and
so at a baseline level this is a bad
start
when you look back at the last many
years there has really only been one
major expansion of mental health
spending and coverage and it's called
the Affordable Care Act also known as
Obamacare remember Obamacare and the
Affordable Care Act are the same thing I
know it's wild that I have to mention
that but I do
um and Republicans regularly
vote against all other attempts as I've
talked about with Greg Abbott or we will
talk about with Greg Abbott as I talked
about with Congressman Tony Gonzalez
Republicans regularly vote against
attempts to increase funding and
increase access to mental health
treatment so at a core level when we say
mental health mental illness red states
are disproportionately underfunded when
it comes to access so it's a perfectly
logical conclusion
you've got more Republicans than
Democrats in red States red states have
lower funding for mental health
treatment
increasingly mental illness you would
expect would skew towards being a
republican problem at to be clear it
doesn't mean at all that there aren't
millions of lefties and Democrats Etc
who struggle with mental illness but
when you look at access and treatment
and funding it's going to skew as a more
as a bigger problem to the right but
it's more than that the problem
in terms of Mental Health
isn't just health care it's also about
economic care we know about the crushing
effect on one's uh uh mood and cognitive
State and mental health status of being
unable to take time off from work when
you need it of knowing that you're going
to be able to just pay your basic bills
of uh feeling like there's no Economic
Opportunity where you are and when you
look at all of these different things
when you look at right-wing Economic
Policy versus left-wing Economic Policy
the economic realities of red States we
know are much more negatively impactful
on mental health and and sort of the
state of one's mood than those economic
policies in blue leaning States again
these are averages we're talking
generally now there's another layer
which tamaski doesn't talk about in the
piece which I want to add
which is when we talk about a lot of
these right-wing ideas
they sound almost what we might call
mentally ill now I want to be really
careful we we may not literally mean
mentally ill in all of these cases okay
we we're not stigmatizing mental illness
we're also not using it as an insult but
when you hear the idea
give teachers guns and have them defend
classrooms
it sounds like what you would say
is an insane idea it's disconnected from
reality only someone who has something
wrong either significant ignorance or
some kind of mental disturbance would
suggest because it doesn't make any
sense and we can go further there was a
recent poll 20 or more of the Republican
Party believes at least some q and on
conspiracies okay is it literally
diagnostic mental illness no it's not
but a lot of this ideology borders on
people who are uh having some kind of
block where they're not connected to the
real world
there's a delusional nature to it after
the 2020 election 57 of trump voters
believed that Trump won Trump didn't win
Joe Biden won Joe Biden easily won the
popular vote Joe Biden easily won the
electoral vote no one state would have
changed that of the states that were in
play Trump didn't win Trump lost and yet
57 percent of his voters believed that
he had won at some point we have to say
well there's a delusional nature to it
is it diagnostically delusional well
that you'd have to examine everybody in
mental health professionals would have
to make the call uh but when we talk
about mental health the fact that
they're saying well just fix Guns by
dealing with the fixed shootings by
dealing with mental health rather than
guns well at the micro level they vote
against doing that all the time
they don't want to fund mental health
treatment they don't want to do any of
it but when we say it's a mental illness
problem what are we really saying and
when you step back and look at the state
of American politics and you look at
where access to mental health treatment
is funded and you look at the delusional
nature of a lot of these ideas like
again I know I always use this example
we're not talking about a difference as
to whether the top tax rate should be 20
35 or 50 percent okay that this is a
different thing we're talking about
something that is fundamentally
delusional and you need only look at the
NRA convention you need to only look at
the so-called suggestions that they're
coming up with to deal with the gun
violence issue to see that so I'm not
diagnosing anybody I'm not stigmatizing
mental illness and I'm not ridiculing
mental illness I'm also not using the
term mental illness as a cudgel to
attack people with but I am pointing out
that when we talk about mental illness
broadly
we really have to dig into what is
happening state by state to understand
the implications of number one not
properly funding dealing with mental
health issues and number two pointing to
them in some vague way when we blame
shootings but then all of a sudden we
can't say hey half of the ideas
associated with trumpism are delusional
colloquially
um
that I I'm sort of at a a loss for words
to go further but I'm very curious to
hear from you what do you think find me
on Twitter at dpacman and remember that
Tuesday June 14th at 6 PM we'll be doing
our next David Pacman show viewer Town
Hall it will be streaming live
exclusively on the Pac-Man Live YouTube
channel that's our second YouTube
channel subscribe there and we're very
much looking forward to that next town
hall